what I'm really happy about is feminism
fought for women to work now I know
there was property owners in the 1600s
and I know that in the early 1900s or
late late 1800s we had our first female
millionaire I know we had Emperors and
emperorses and you know there was women
that were so influential that men
traveled hundreds of thousands of miles
to get wisdom from them but you know we
just couldn't work we were just so
impressed we just had such a hard
horrible time and we just needed to
fight the patriarchy yeah we had to
fight for our rights and thank God we
got the right to to vote and the right
to go to work and just do all of these
amazing things we have a woman that is
breaking barriers and claiming to make
seven thousand dollars a day wow one of
our first female millionaires I'm sure
she added so much value to society